qu'entend le guillou ce bonjour merci de
répondre à notre question donc
négociation en ce moment même à
bruxelles sur le budget européen et
notamment la pac
êtes vous confiant sur le fait que la
france puisse maintenir son niveau de
subventions liées à la pac
on va essayer d'être confiant maintenant
il ya environ une vingtaine de pays qui
qui sont contre cette baisse donc on
espère qu'ils vont réussir à se faire
entendre contre les les quatre pays du
nord de l'europe qui le veulent à tout
prix une baisse
cette baisse a été limitée a été
beaucoup plus importante en début d'un
début de discussions aujourd'hui on est
arrivé à une baisse de 80 milliards
d'euros pour nous en france voilà une
baisse c'est plus acceptable la pac
diminue d'année en année 80 milliards
d'euros c'est c'est un pack c'est énorme
et comment est ce que vous avez
accueilli le rétropédalage du ministre
de l'agriculture
didier guillaume il avait dit que le
budget avait été maintenu et finalement
il a dit non ce n'est pas encore acté il
va falloir donc attendre à on
l'accueille comme comme un message voilà
soucis de connexion on vient de perdre
quentin le guillou ce qu'on leur trouve
un peut-être d'ici avec quelques
quelques instants les vingt-sept sont
donc en train de négocier depuis hier le
budget européen poste brigitte mon cas à
gagner sur les sept prochaines années un
peu plus de 60 milliards d'euros
le parlement européen refuse l'offre du
conseil européen en 2000 95 milliards
d'euros
la position du parlement est très claire
la proposition présentée est
inacceptable et elle ne sera pas votée
j'ai été très clair j'ai bien sûr a
ajouté que nous attendons un résultat
positif des travaux du conseil et nous
espérons qu'il sera à la hauteur des
ambitions de l'union européenne
on a retrouvé quentin le guillou cela je
vous posais la question comment est ce
que vous aviez accueilli le
rétropédalage de didier guillaume le
ministre de l'agriculture
oui donc on l'a aperçu quand même assez
mal c'est encore une promesse en l'air
du gouvernement bon maintenant le
gouvernement n'est pas le seul fautif là
dedans il ya l'europe via bruxelles
voilà donc j'espère qu'ils vont réussir
à trouver une entente
et puis éviter encore de faire sortir
les agriculteurs dans les rues et puis
s'il faut monter à bruxelles et à
l'europe pour se faire entendre
je pense que on peut être capable on
peut être capable essayer de se faire
entendre à bruxelles demain ali à
l'ouverture du salon de l'agriculture à
paris emmanuel macron est attendu du
côté de la porte de versailles des
manifestants a également qui s'opposent
à sa venue sont attendus aussi et vous
qu'est ce que vous attendez du
gouvernement et de l'elysée
on attend des réponses claires sur
toutes les problématiques qu'on peut
avoir depuis un an et puis les nouvelles
qui vont arriver éventuellement bas avec
la pac c'est encore un coup de massue
supplémentaire sur l'agriculteur ça fait
un an qu'on se bataillent avec les
alertes et les zones d'entraînement
abords des habitations avec les objets
acquis devraient être mis en application
depuis déjà pratiquement un an elles ont
été mis en application en des sanctions
et des nouvelles normes pour
l'agriculteur mais elles n'ont pas
encore été mises en application
pour les grandes surfaces et les
distributeurs donc on aimerait que
monsieur macron nous répondent
et puis qu'ils prennent un petit peu les
choses en main et qu'il applique ce
qu'il a dit au niveau des deux géants et
puis qu'on arrive aussi encore discuter
sur les mnt qui pour rappel on avait
demandé que l'âne c'est ce qui s'occupe
de la vie scientifique donne son rapport
et que le gouvernement s'appuie sur 7
sur cette donnée malheureusement le
gouvernement n'a pas encore a coûté
ecoutez-le hans hess qui elle-même n'a
pas encore rendu son rapport et on
attend on attend on attend sauf que en
france les choses aime traîner
vous venez donc de parler un des
pesticides du glyphosate et zones
d'épandage
il ya beaucoup d'aghrib aching en ce
moment on en entend beaucoup parler de
ce mot il ya une récente étude de la
chambre d'agriculture de la saône et
loire qui s'inquiètent du pessimisme des
agriculteurs lié donc notamment à cet
agrès bashing il serait 60% dans ce cas
et un sur trois serait proche du burn
out
comment c'est ce qu'on peut sortir de
l'impasse comment on peut sortir la
passe très bonne question on cherche on
essaye de ramener une nouvelle forme de
communication on a des nouveaux nouveaux
agriculteurs qui se lance avec youtube
essayer de montrer les faire on ouvre
les fermes on montre aux gens en changer
l'opinion
voilà on essaie de changer aussi
l'opinion vis-à-vis de certains médias
on a des médias malheureusement qui qui
ont aidé à cet agrès machine à force de
lancer des émissions à tort et à travers
avec éventuellement une émission télé
qui a amené des célébrités à faire leurs
besoins dans un pot on est en analyse
voilà donc ça ça ça nous a tapé dedans
pour que finalement nous mêmes on fasse
des analyses aussi et qu'on contredisent
tous qui viennent de lire puisque
malheureusement bas nous les analyses
qu'on a réussi à faire il s'avère
totalement bonne sauf que ben le public
a entendu le premier qui criaient et
souvent c'est celui-là qu'on entend le
plus et qu'on garde un esprit
voilà on essaye de changer l'opinion en
changeant de type l'opinion des gens on
pourrait peut-être limiter cet agrès
machine et vivre plus en harmonie avec
avec le grand public le consommateur le
citoyen merci comptant le guillou
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes représentants des
jeunes agriculteurs d'île de france